- [Narrator] Thora Birch is an actress.
She's been in a lot of movies.
Like ...
a lot of movies.
- I'm trying to find myself.
- [Narrator] Let's settle
in and listen to a few tales
from some of Thora's most iconic films.
- So whatever I say, just smile and nod.
(lively orchestral music)
- Hi, my name is Thora
Birch, and I've been acting
in film and television
since I was four years old.
The beginning of the ‘90s with Hocus Pocus.
I was kind of cast as the sassy blonde kid
that always had something
a little bit too smart
for her own age to say.
- Stuff it, zit face!
- Well, I remember with Hocus Pocus
that I was so thrilled to
have been a part of it,
to have worked with Bette Midler.
And I fell in love with Kathy Najimy
and Sarah Jessica Parker.
But it came out at an awkward time.
It didn't really come
out around Halloween.
(screaming)
And then, 10 years after that,
people would come up to me and be
like, "Hey, wait a second,
"are you Danny from Hocus Pocus?"
And I'd be like, "Wait, wait, what?
"Hocus Pocus, what are you talking about?"
And then it just like ...
My awareness of it
growing into this kind of
cult-like thing, I was
like, "Oh, okay, wow.
"It's got a long life."
What I loved about Now & Then
was it was about friendships
and how important they are.
It's a coming-of-age movie.
And also, we had a female writer,
we had a female director,
female producers.
It was very much female empowerment.
For a group of 12-year-old
girls to be working
on a film like that, I didn't even realize
how important it was at the time.
American Beauty, I would love to say
that I didn't relate to Jane
in any way, shape or form,
and that I was so much more
fun-loving than she was,
but no, there was a soulful connection
to her malaise.
But what I did also respond
to specifically was that,
through the course of the
film, she herself changed.
The Jane at the end of
the film is very different
from the Jane that we first
meet at the beginning.
Well, for me the beginning
of the ‘90s with Hocus Pocus,
to the end of the 90s,
shooting American Beauty,
it was almost like being
in a different decade.
Things had changed that much,
but also I grew up and changed that much.
Having done this since the
age of like four-and-a-half,
I've learned different
things from different shoots.
It's not so much about
waiting for one experience
that's gonna be like a
career-defining thing.
I think it's just enjoying the moment
and what you're presented with today.
(climactic music)